punchy co qu'est ce que ça fait comme
impression de travailler avec suzanne
flon à profit pour l'affiché avec les
micros à dans la fesse a fait que c'est
un très grand privilège pour un gamin
mois 1 d'autant je fais très peu de
théâtre
d'abord le fait de jouer cette très
belle pièce de loleh bellon ce qu'un
plaisir et puis la présence de suzanne
et la commune une grande prêtresse du
mensonge et moi côté d'elle comme un
d'apprentis parce que je crois que ce
métier est initiatique
je prends des notes tous les soirs je la
regarde et on n'a pas véritablement la
sensation de d'un effort
j'ai l'impression que tout ça se passe
très naturellement c'est ce qu'il ya de
plus impressionnant chez suzanne ses 7,7
vraie vérité ça peut se dire ça oui
un qui finale de l'amt hôtes allemands
et et qui est maîtrisée par une immense
technique est bien qu'elle se soit
encore une gamine je viens je bête
[Musique]